hello good afternoon everyone my name is
freon at origin I'm an astrophysicist
and faculty member in the department's
of astronomy and physics at Yale I also
serve currently as the director of the
Frankie program in science in the
humanities I'm absolutely delighted to
welcome you all to the frankly
distinguished lecture series I would
first like to thank the donors for
Richard and Barbara Frankie who's
generous support has made this possible
before I introduce today's star speaker
has been a real coup for us to be able
to get him to host him and hear him
today I need to make a few practical
announcements I'm required to give you
all notice that this event is being
recorded and photographed for
educational archival and promotional
purposes including use and print on the
internet and other forms of media by
attending this event today you agree to
the possibility of your voice or
likeness captured by these means and
used for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby waive any
related right of privacy or publicity
and I also want to announce our
continuing first in a practical way that
immediately following the lecture please
do join us for a reception in room 108
to celebrate and to continue the
conversation now to today's speaker
Steven Strogatz
Steve is a Jacob Gould Sherman professor
of applied mathematics at Cornell
University after graduating summa [ __ ]
laude in mathematics from Princeton in
1980 Steve studied at Trinity College
Cambridge my alma mater where he was a
Marshall scholar he did his doctoral
work in applied mathematics at Harvard
followed by a National Science
Foundation postdoctoral fellowship also
at Harvard from 1989 to 1994 he taught
at MIT before joining the Cornell
faculty in 1994 where he has been since
what is really remarkable about Steve is
the originality that he brings to his
broad set of research interests in
mathematics
early in his career he worked on a
variety of problems in mathematical
biology which was a brand-new field at
the time studying the geometry of super
coil DNA the dynamics of the human
sleep-wake cycle the topology of
three-dimensional chemical
waves and the collective behavior of
biological oscillators such as swarms of
synchronously flashing fireflies in the
1990s his work focused more into another
exciting and challenging area of
mathematics nonlinear dynamics and chaos
as applied to physics engineering and
biology and many of you probably have
used his textbook at some point or the
other several of these projects of his
dealt with coupled oscillators such as
lasers superconducting Josephson
junctions and crickets that chirp in
unison and I have juxtaposed these
things just to show you what the range
of the systems to which he has been
applying mathematical structures to in
each case his research involved close
collaborations with experimentalist he
also likes boldly branching out into new
areas often with students taking the
lead in the past few years this has led
him to such topics fun topics as the
role of crowd synchronization in the
wobbling of London's Millennium Bridge
on its opening day and the dynamics of
structural balance in social systems one
of his seminal research contributions is
a landmark 1998 nature paper on small
world networks that was co-authored with
his former student Duncan Watts this is
considered to be one of the most
influential papers in network science
and was you know it was the most highly
cited paper on networks for decades as
well as the sixth most highly cited
paper on any topic in physics it has now
been cited more than 38,000 times
according to Google Scholar Steve has
received numerous awards for his
research his teaching and his public
communication and enumerated all of them
would take up too much time so I will
just mention two most recent awards the
Lewis Thomas prize for writing about
science which honors the scientist as
poet and the same george pólya prize for
mathematical exposition so one of the
unique things about Steve in addition to
his
working mathematics he's deeply devoted
to the public dissemination of
mathematics he has been elected to many
many prestigious societies for both of
these kinds of work both his research
work and the work he does in
popularizing and making increasing
mathematical literacy he's a fellow of
the Society of industrial in applied
mathematics the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences the American Physical
Society and the American Mathematical
Society and of course he's spoken at all
the shishi venues Ted Aspen ideas
festival etc etc and he's a frequent
guest on radio lab and Science Friday
and he is the author of nonlinear
dynamics and chaos which is a 1994
textbook which is the standard on in
this subject and in 2009 starting in
2003 he started writing much more for
the public as well as his research work
in 2003 he wrote a book called sink 2009
the calculus of friendship and 2012 book
that most of you probably heard about
the joy of X which incidentally has been
translated into about 15 languages his
current book infinite powers will form
the basis of his talk today so in
closing I want to quote the
mathematician Georg Cantor who said
mathematicians do not study pure
mathematics because it's useful they
study it because it delights them and
they delight in it because it's
beautiful so without further ado it's my
pleasure to invite Steven Strogatz who
will be speaking to us today about the
beauty of calculus
welcome thanks for coming I'm very
delighted to be here I just drove down
from Ithaca and felt good to be back in
Connecticut I'm a Connecticut boy grew
up in Torrington just go right up Rudy
it's an interesting choice of quote you
mentioning Cantor's quote because I'm an
applied mathematician so I don't know
that I really agree with Cantor I do
delight in the usefulness of mathematics
but I also certainly delight in the
beauty like all mathematicians we have
the exciting feature today that I don't
have a computer in front of me and we're
gonna do this old school the Dean of
science is here to help me go through my
slides so I will I mean it may seem a
little bit strange but I'm gonna be
saying next next next and he'll be he's
gonna toggle through we think this will
work so bear with us if it doesn't but
hopefully it will we have not rehearsed
thank you Jeff for agreeing to do it
okay next
should I say next what's the coolest
thing to say next okay
yeah next all right no don't do next
well so yeah on this theme of calculus
being useful it's it's an unsung hero of
our existence it's everywhere and you
may not realize it but without calculus
we wouldn't have radio television
microwave ovens yeah you can kind of go
through them fairly quickly because
these are all just we wouldn't have been
able to put astronauts on the moon
unravel the human genome we wouldn't
have nuclear energy or nuclear weapons
we wouldn't have ultrasound for
expectant mothers or GPS for lost
travelers and we might not even have the
Declaration of Independence now some of
these I realize may seem far-fetched I'd
be happy to talk at the end if you want
me to try to defend any of these some of
the connections are tenuous but I think
I could make a case for everything I've
just said there so it's it's invisible I
mean most of us have no idea that
calculus is a part of all of these
things and many more but it really is
next so the take-home message from that
is that calculus help make the world
modern now of course it didn't do it on
its own it wasn't calculus that put
people on the moon you needed engineers
you need physicists so it's a think of
it as like in a drama you know in a
theater there are supporting players
this is calculus is sort of the
supporting player that you've seen in
every movie or every play and you never
really noticed that it was there but
it's a very important player in the
drama next now the question is at least
the first question here's a branch of
math that many people find sort of
arcane and abstruse certainly a lot of
freshmen taking freshman calculus would
say I don't see the point of calculus
both before they took the course and
after they took the course and a lot of
the students taking Advanced Placement
calculus and I daresay many of their
teachers would be hard-pressed to say
why are we doing this exactly you know
calculus is in such a big rush there's
so much to cover to get ready for the
advanced placement test or for whatever
there's so many techniques to learn so
many theorems to be understood so much
jargon to absorb that the larger context
is often excluded or just not even you
know it no one would even think of
including the history the applications
the philosophy the connections to
medicine and physics and sociology and
everything else but I want to try to
give you the big picture of calculus and
I don't assume that you've had it or
that you even know what it is now it
could be that you know I don't know you
may be ringers out there maybe all of
you are mathematicians right but I don't
assume that this this lecture series as
you may know is supposed to be a meeting
ground for the humanities and Sciences
and I'm very grateful to the Franky's
for you know for sponsoring this
colloquium series it's fantastic to
bring the humanists and the scientists
and the mathematicians together so in
that spirit I'm going to be avoiding for
the most part technical math because
it's really not very realistic to do
that if you've never thought about these
things before but I do want to give you
the flavor of some of the gorgeous
arguments and
and and the stories of why calculus is
so important so the question I'm asking
there is you know here's this arcane
branch of math how could it be that it
helped to reshape civilization and I'm
making a little word game there because
it grew out of geometry it was
originally about shapes and it reshaped
the world okay next
so in the spirit of humanities trying to
find common ground with the sciences and
with math I want to tell you a little
story first of two men who met I'd say
it was probably the late 1940s early
1950s so my parents would have
recognized this gentleman maybe a lot of
you will not know who he is
Herman woke was a great novelist he's
actually still alive he's 103 years old
but in my parents generation he was the
chronicler of World War two for a mass
audience and so he wrote these famous
books winds of war war and remembrance
novels you'll probably have heard of the
King mutiny Humphrey Bogart was in the
movie that's his first I think was maybe
his first book Pulitzer Prize winning
book so woke wanted to write a book
about World War 2 this was before I mean
that book the book II had in mind grew
into two big books those two books winds
of war and war in remembrance but at the
time he had this vision of I'm gonna
write a great novel about world war two
he was in the war himself as a sailor
and he wanted in particular to interview
some scientists who had worked on the
Manhattan Project on the building of the
atomic bomb and he was told that you
could find people like this at Caltech
and if you go to Caltech there's someone
that you should meet but he's difficult
named Richard Fineman so let's have the
next slide there's Richard Feinman you
see him there in a classroom those are
the days when it was all boys probably
Caltech is still quite I think isn't it
pretty bad gender ratio I think so but
anyway in those days probably a hundred
percent but you know he was a joker you
see him there playing the bongos he used
to break into safes Los Alamos
he's written many books chronicling his
escapades he he loved to tell stories
about himself he's a joker there's also
a great teacher and had a very deep
understanding of physics and won a Nobel
Prize for his work in an area called
quantum electrodynamics
but anyway so he's sitting there when he
had worked on the Manhattan Project he
was very young like maybe early 20s so
woke comes to see him they start talking
they talk they have a lot in common it
turns out they're about the same age
they're both Jewish there's a difference
you know Fineman is quite an extreme
atheist woek is very devout and so
they'd get to talking they like each
other and they're having fun back and
forth talking about things arguing about
science and religion and then after they
leave just as woek as leaving walking
out the door Fineman says i have a
question for you do you know calculus
and woke admits you know no i don't and
finance says well you had better learn
it it's the language God talks so I want
I want to leave you with that thought
right now the language God talks next
slide that's a book then that became the
title of Herman wokes book about science
and religion sparked by his
confrontation with I mean if you want to
call it confrontation his meeting with
Fineman and it's a terrific book it
includes his conversations with Steven
Weinberg and various other well-known
physicists I don't know if you can read
it but the subtitle is on science and
religion so if you've ever wondered
about trying to reconcile your faith
with science or can they be reconciled
they certainly address a lot of the same
deep mysteries this could be an
interesting book for you to look at but
anyway so the language God talks now
woke as I say did not know calculus and
he tells a little story in the book
about how you know if this is the
language God talks maybe he should learn
it so he describes his efforts to go out
and try to learn calculus and I take
that as sort of a metaphor for what I
think we're trying to do here today that
here's someone from the humanity
making a good-faith effort to try to
learn what we have to offer in math so
next slide lope tells this little story
of how he says he went to the bookstore
or he skimmed some freshmen textbooks
hoping to come across one that might
help a mathematical ignoramus like me
who had spent his college years in the
humanities ie literature and philosophy
in an adolescent quest for the meaning
of existence little knowing the calculus
which I had heard of as a difficult bore
leading nowhere was the language God
talks so he sets out to teach himself
calculus he tries reading books with
titles like calculus made easy he hires
an Israeli tutor to help him learn his
Hebrew better at the same time learning
some math he none of this is working he
goes to he finally in desperation he
goes to a high school and enrolls in the
high school calculus class and after a
few weeks he falls behind and gives up
and leaves and as he's walking out the
students clap for him and he says it's
like you know when there's a pitiful
showbiz act there's this concept of
sympathy applause that's what he felt
like so he had this really hard - he
could not manage to learn calculus and
so I want to dedicate my book to Herman
Wouk I've never met him I don't know him
I sent him a copy he's in a home
somewhere I mean he's very very old his
wife recently died I mean I think it's
probably very hard for him at 103 right
now but next slide so yeah so infinite
powers is is my attempt to write for
people like Herman woke in the
humanities what is the reason that
anyone would think that calculus is the
language God talks why should have so
does my wife would tease me for saying
like this why should a normal person
learn calculus and by the way I don't
feel necessarily you need to learn
calculus this is a story about
appreciating calculus you don't have to
learn it to be able to appreciate it so
first let me try to address this
question of fineman's cryptic comment
the language God talks what did he mean
I want to try to illustrate what I think
he might have meant with an anecdote
about electricity and magnetism so
electricity here's a picture of my
daughter Leah my older daughter I have
two daughters but so when Leah was four
years old there she is at her
grandmother's house and she's playing on
the bed and it was winter and you know
static electricity made her hair do that
and I took a picture of it and you've
probably had similar experiences with
static electricity so electricity is
something we all kind of know about from
playing with static electricity from the
electricity that we can plug into in the
wall
there's also magnetism next slide which
you know if you take a magnet so there's
a magnet with north and south poles the
north pole in red and if you sprinkle
these so-called iron filings little
slivers of iron on paper around the
magnet and kind of shaked it so that
everything has a chance to move if it
wants to the filings form this amazing
pattern around the magnet which we take
as indication that there's this
invisible field of force around the
magnet the magnetic field and these
filings these iron filings can help us
visualize this amazing pattern of force
the directions that the magnetic field
is pulling on on things depending on
where you are so you've got these
concepts of electricity and magnetism
which in the 1800s when scientists first
began to really try to understand them
scientifically by doing experiments on
you know electrical currents magnets and
the relationship between them and here
I'm thinking of people like ampere and
Faraday Coulomb lens I mean if you've
taken freshman physics you wilford these
names so this is a great era of
discovering the laws of how magnets and
electricity work and how they're
interrelated the the key concept turned
out to be the idea of a field this this
invisible pattern of force around
magnets and around current-carrying
wires and so on and so Michael Faraday
had the idea of the field but he was not
very mathematical
it was a later person named James Clerk
Maxwell next slide there's a picture of
Maxwell as a young man usually if you
know Maxwell's pictures he looks like an
old man with a big beard and and that
was him later in life but this is
Maxwell as a young man Scottish
physicist working in the mid-1800s and
he realized that these fields that
Faraday and others were talking about
could be given a mathematical
description and when he tried to give a
description of all the laws that had
been discovered by ampere Faraday and
others he found that calculus was the
perfect language for describing what had
been discovered about electric and
magnetic fields but here's the part that
gets spooky I mean we're finding uses
the term the language that God talks and
you always hear people say oh well math
is a language yes that's partly true
math is a language but it's much more
than a language and this analogy is
missing something and this is the part
that I consider a bit uncanny and I
think it's what Fineman had in mind when
he said it's the language such as a
language it's the language God talks in
this sense that when when Maxwell looked
at what he had written down his
equations that encoded all the known
facts about electric and magnetic fields
he had done a translation from physics
into the language of calculus but then
he could do more with calculus which is
he could start to operate on the
equations he could manipulate them I
mean in math we use that word manipulate
the equation I want you to think about
it literally like you go to the masseuse
because you have a kink in your back she
will manipulate you
she will massage you and she will work
on you and you might start to relax and
say something and that's what happens to
Maxwell's equations as he starts
manipulating them by adding one to
another or in our language he takes the
divergence of huan'er he takes the curl
of another he's doing mathematical
manipulations on them trying to get them
to open up and talk to him and reveal
their secrets and he doesn't know what
he's looking for he just knows that he
wants something to come out and as he's
manipulating at some point he sees and
by the way what does this mean really
you're transforming the equations from
one form into another form that's
logically mathematically equivalent so
in a way you're doing nothing it's just
one thing that's I mean if you had
Lalaji
you could see the chain of reasoning in
your mind you wouldn't need the math
he's basically constructing a long
argument that's what the symbols are
doing for him I mean that's why we use
this it's not just a language it's a
system of reasoning so he's doing his
reasoning on the equations and at some
point he recognizes a new equation that
has come out because it's the same
equation that describes the spread of
ripples on a pond
it's the equation for how waves move and
accept that this is a wave of
electricity and magnetism where the
electricity the electric field is
generating a magnetic field which then
regenerates the electric field and
they're doing this kind of dance a pod
to do it together dancing propagating
and he calculates we're always
interested in a way of how fast does it
travel he plugs in the numbers and it
turns out it propagates at the speed of
light which had been measured around
that time for the first time so this I
think must have been one of the greatest
aha moments in human history that in
that moment and I wish I could be there
I mean we all wish we could be there
watching Maxwell as he realizes what
light is I mean humanity had known about
light forever but we never knew what it
really was now we suddenly knew light is
an electromagnetic wave so what was that
that happened there that day I mean that
was calculus as a language and as a
system of reasoning and it was if
Maxwell had tapped into something that
that is built into the structure of the
universe he wasn't just talking I mean
he wasn't like being a poet he was
actually learning the language that the
universe is speaking so there's this
prediction that electromagnetic waves
exist that they propagate at the speed
of light next slide yeah click and so
1860s he predicts this within a few
years Heinrich Hertz measures
electromagnetic waves they're real they
do exist
soon Tesla is using them to create the
first radio systems and to do wireless
transmission of
energy and then Marconi is sending
messages across the atlantic ocean and
you know you have the birth of the
Telegraph and very soon after click we
have radio we have television we have
wireless so it's not correct to say that
Calculus created this but calculus was
indispensable I mean if it weren't for
Maxwell and his calculus these all these
things that we take for granted today
they may have still been discovered
anyway but maybe later or maybe not at
all so so that's what I think Fineman is
talking about that Maxwell's equations
are telling us something about the
universe not just it's not just a
language it's a language about something
very deep next slide so you may have
seen these t-shirts you know this is a
standard nerdy t-shirt you can get and
God said and then there's Maxwell's
equations and then there was light so
let's see I don't have a pointer but or
do I no I don't think I do no all right
I'll do all you don't need to be able to
read that language just to see that
those symbols what's going on on the
left where there's an upside-down
triangle that's talking about electric
and magnetic fields and how they change
in space how they change as you move
from some point like think of those iron
filings around the magnet if you look at
one of the filings and then move to the
next one nearby the direction may change
a little bit how exactly the field is
changing in space is encoded by what's
going on on the left and then what's
going on on the right is you might see
that there's a symbol T in the
denominator of one of those fractions
that T refers to time it's talking about
how the magnetic and electric fields are
changing in time and how that is
influenced by how they're changing in
space so there's this interaction
between you know things happening in
space and time encoded in this and like
I say these four equations then imply
the existence of electromagnetic waves
although it's not obvious you have to be
good at calculus and this particular
part of calculus called differential
equations which is what these are these
are for differential equations the word
differential meaning that they express
how things
change from one point to another or from
one moment to another those are
differences in time or space so that's
the difference in differential okay
let's move on so next slide now so the
larger point though I mean Maxwell is
just supposed to illustrate this broader
point why calculus matters this is my
claim sort of the thesis of the whole
book so if you want to just get the
punchline they say it's good to give the
punchline at the beginning because
people will space out and get tired so
I'm giving it to you right now the rest
you can start checking your email or
whatever you do but why does calculus
matter here's the argument first because
the laws of nature happen to be written
in this particular language in the
language of calculus second because
calculus is more than a language it's a
system of reasoning that taps into
something about the structure of the
universe it's as if the universe runs on
calculus if you want me to say it that
way I mean I'm getting a little mystical
here but I think it's true in that we
see this again and again not just with
the laws of electricity and magnetism
but if you look at Einsteins laws about
how gravity works encoded in general
relativity which I was just listening to
in Priya's book mapping the heavens
which I highly highly recommend if you
want a great book about astronomy and
astrophysics but so Einstein's equations
or differential equations Newton's laws
of motion and gravity differential
equations the laws of how fluids move
like air and water differential
equations everything under the Sun that
we understand in mathematical terms we
understand through differential
equations ie calculus it is the language
God talks next by learning to speak this
strange language I mean it took humanity
thousands of years to learn this
language but by learning to speak it and
discovering that it is somehow tapping
into this deep structure of the laws of
nature we've been able to use calculus
you know in combination with science and
technology to remake the world that's
the argument now how did this all happen
I mean we didn't start with Maxwell
remember Maxwell was at the time of the
Civil War that's 1860 something we
didn't begin with that we began
thousands of years or
it's commonly you know many books will
tell you calculus was invented by Newton
and live nets in the 1600s I don't think
that's the right point of view I think
that's way too parochial of view of what
was really happening I would much rather
say we we started calculus a few
thousand years before that next slide so
I'll try to explain why and to do this
let me try to personify calculus I think
it's the easiest way to think about it
think of it as if it were a person um
that is not really a person of course
it's in it it's a subject but when I say
what calculus wants I guess you could
then if you're very literal-minded you
should hear that as what the
practitioners of calculus want the
people who do calculus what is it that
we want the books textbooks about
calculus are like a thousand pages long
they're very heavy they weigh like
cinderblock wait what what is in there
what are we trying to do it looks very
complicated but that's misleading what
calculus wants is simplicity it the
reason it looks so bulky is it's
tackling very hard complicated problems
and it wants to make them simpler
calculus is all about what do you do to
make difficult problems easier and it
has a grand strategy and this strategy
is buried under all the minutiae of
derivatives and integrals for those of
you who have taken calculus you learned
about doing substitutions in every other
possible trick that stuff is distracting
that here's the real point what is
calculus really about I will now tell
you next here's how it gets what it
wants it has one big idea and this idea
runs like a theme you know in a musical
theme and variations there is one idea
in calculus and if you get this one idea
which for some reason we never tell the
students this idea but everybody who
knows calculus knows it Jeff the
mathematician will tell you I'll check
this on you you tell me if you agree
this is the one big idea the big idea is
that we're gonna make problems easier by
slicing them into smaller problems now
that is an idea everybody has who knows
how to solve problems to make a hard
problem easier make it smaller break it
into parts and work on the parts that's
an ancient idea the crazy idea of
calculus is
stop do that forever do that ad
infinitum next this is the big idea I'm
gonna call it the infinity principle
nobody else calls it that I'm just
making it up but but this is what I
think is the heart of calculus is that
you can make problems easier by slicing
them and slicing them and slicing them
all the way to infinity next so you keep
doing that forever and then what are you
left with your left next you're left
with infinitely many infinitesimally
tiny pieces and the philosophy is that
those pieces whether they're short
pieces of a curve or little patches of a
surface or instants in time or tiny bits
of material whatever it is that tiny
thing is going to be much more
manageable than the original big thing
and so the strategy is a two-stage
strategy first you cut the thing down to
the smallest infinitesimal bits next you
solve the problem for the tiny pieces
that turns out usually to be fairly easy
that's why you did this next then you
have to put the answers back together to
get the original hole that tends to be
hard very hard there's no free lunch so
putting the pieces back together is what
makes calculus hard but it turns out it
will be easier than dealing with the
original problem without this strategy
so this is the best thing we've ever
thought of it's one of the great ideas
in human history up there with human
rights democracy evolution quantum
mechanics I mean this one idea the
infinity principle has had as big of a
consequential impact on the world as I
think just about any other idea next
so the jargon you've heard of
differential calculus that's what we
call the operation of slicing and taking
the tiny pieces calculating derivatives
amounts to this putting them back
together that's the hard part that's
called integral calculus and so if
you've taken calculus you know that you
learn derivatives before integrals
that's why because differential calculus
is easier you do that first now there's
a key assumption in this when we say
that we're gonna chop problems into
their tiniest bits we're assuming that
we can do that forever this is the
importance of being continuous next the
infinity principle says that
will work I mean this strategy will work
only on those objects that can be
infinitely subdivided endlessly okay if
that's not gonna work well then you
can't use calculus so the calculus only
works on these things that are
infinitely sub divisible we call those
things continuous meaning from the old
Latin roots what con plus tener a would
mean holding together so a continuous
thing is that which holds together in
that sense that it's it's all touching
itself so continuous objects are grist
for calculus next but notice the
creative fantasy in case you think math
is all very objective and rigorous I
want you to want to disabuse you of that
idea that's only half of math that's the
second half the first half is creative
fantasy you have to have imagination and
creativity all math is like that then
you tidy up and make things nice and
logically pristine but at the beginning
it's wild fantasy imagination and desire
and in this case the desire is to
pretend that the world is like this
pretend that everything can be
infinitely divided as much as you want
why is it fantasy because that's not
really correct the world is not like
that we know today depending who you
talk to but but you know this was a
debate going back to the you know the
ancients that when you think about atoms
what's the word atom mean it means
literally a Tom it means uncuttable
right the things though things that
cannot be cut the smallest bit of matter
is an atom that cannot be cut any
further and so the Greeks you know in
the time of Democritus were arguing to
atoms exist is the world grainy is it
made of tiny things or is it infinitely
sub divisible forever and not just
matter but space and time is there a
smallest interval of time is there a
smallest amount of space this is a live
question today if you talk to the string
theorists or people doing quantum
gravity they will tell you yes there is
a smallest thing it's called the Planck
scale after Max Planck there's the
smallest unit of space something like 10
to the minus 35 meters way way way
smaller than the smallest particle that
we know there's a smallest unit of time
which is the time it would take light to
travel that distance
and there's nothing smaller that we know
of so it is not true according to modern
physics that you can infinitely
subdivide time and space and matter do
you think we care about that in calculus
yes and no okay we want to get things
right but we also want to make progress
and so we're gonna pretend that's what I
mean by creative fantasy we will pretend
that the world is infinitely sub
divisible next so calculus then in my
definition and essentially nobody else's
but I think it's it's really the heart
of it is calculus should be thought of
as the use of the Infinity principle to
solve or to shed light on anything
that's continuous whether it's a shape
an object something moving any kind of
phenomenon that's the strategy and so if
I had to boil it down to what calculus
has really been obsessed with it's three
things next oh okay the three are curves
and curved shapes so geometry but
specifically about things not made of
straight lines and flat planes but that
are curved and sinuous that was a big
problem in ancient geometry calculus
came in to solve that and that's where
it began dealing with curves so that let
me go back sorry to let's just go back
one so yeah so we're gonna start with
curves but calculus has you know the
three things that it has focused on
throughout its like twenty five hundred
year history curves motion and change so
if you want a little mantra that's your
mantra curves motion and change some
people like to define calculus as the
mathematics of change that that works
pretty well actually because a curve you
could think of as changing direction and
motion you could think of as changing
position so if you had to say it in one
word calculus is the mathematics of
change but specifically continuous
change never-ending ongoing change okay
next so let's begin with curves now
here's an ancient problem figuring out
properties of a circle you might think
that's trivial I learned that in high
school geometry it's not trivial it's
not easy to figure out like think of how
weird the number pi is right everybody
is fascinated by pi with its infinitely
many
don't show any pattern why is pie so
weird because papaya is a creature of
calculus it's not a creature of geometry
the fact that it has these infinitely
many digits that don't repeat and don't
you a pattern is already a clue that
there's something with the Infinity
principle at work here
you know when high school you just
memorize pie maybe you didn't think why
is that the number how does anyone
calculate that number you have to use
calculus that's how so let me remind you
pi is defined as the ratio of the
circumference of the circle to its
diameter
okay circumference the distance around
diameter the distance across but a big
question if that's a definition of pi
fine that's that's one property of a
circle what about the space inside the
circle the area inside the circle you
may have memorized a formula for the
SATs PI R squared the area of a circle R
is the radius that's half the diameter
the distance from the center of the
circle out to the edge there where does
that formula PI R squared come from
that's a calculus result you will not
find it in Euclid by the way I mean if
you think it's Euclidean geometry you
don't understand you can look at Euclid
you will not find PI R squared and
Euclid Euclid does say the area of a
circle is proportional to the square of
the radius but he doesn't have PI for
him pi is not even a number that's you
know okay so you have to wait till the
like two more generations for Archimedes
and that's when we start to really begin
calculus he's the great maestro of the
Infinity principle our community so
let's see the next slide here's an
argument this is not really Archimedes
argument it's closed in spirit to his
argument for calculating the area of the
circle but if you've never seen it I
want to show it to you because I think
it's very dramatic and it's an example
of what it feels like to have an aha
moment in math okay so what I'm doing
there is I'm taking a circle and I've
chopped it into four pieces you could
think of them as slices of pizza if you
want to an abstract mathematical pizza
and I'm rearranging those slices into
this funny shape on the bottom which
I'll refer to as a scalloped shape
because you know it's got these bulbous
curves on the bottom and I've put on the
bottom PI R to indicate that the amount
of
rust if you thought of it as a pizza the
length of the crust on the bottom is pi
times the radius why am I saying that
the whole crust is 2 pi times the radius
right that's the circumference pi times
the diameter the diameter is 2 times the
radius so 2 PI R is the circumference
half of the circumference half of the
curvy part is on the bottom half is on
the top so it's PI R on the bottom and
then the edge of the pizza that straight
piece this piece that was that's just
the radius of the pizza so at the moment
the strategy is if we could figure out
the area of that thing we would then
know the area of the circle the trouble
is we've looked like we need the problem
worse that shape is harder than the
circle but what we're gonna try to do is
somehow with the use of the Infinity
principle change the circle into a shape
whose area we know that's the grand
strategy all right so next slide the
thought is maybe the reason that shape
on the bottom was bad is we didn't take
enough slices so instead of taking 4
slices what if you take 8 and you
arrange them like this you can you see
that the shape is getting better it
looks like it's trying to turn into some
shape you recognize anyone want to
volunteer what shape it looks like it's
trying to become what but looks like
it's trying to be a parallelogram right
it's almost a parallelogram because this
side is parallel to that side the bottom
is not straight like it's supposed to be
in a parallelogram a little bit curvy
but um here's I want to test your
dexterity for saying it Jeff can you
toggle back and forth where what I mean
is when you go to the optometrist they
will sometimes say better worse better
or worse can you do that between the two
slides better worse which is better
better okay go one more forward better
ok that's was 16 that's better now can
you see what's happening actually keep
your eye on the tilt of this side can we
do that go back 1 see it's more tilted
and more so now going forward it's
getting less tilted if you did this
infinitely often you'd have infinitely
many infinitesimally thin slices but
they would be standing upright and you
would get that isn't that cool
and notice the
time the bottom was always length half
the circle PI R and this was always the
radius so now you know how to find the
area of a rectangle the length times the
height ya PI R times R that's PI R
squared that is basically the real
reason the area of a circle is PI R
squared because it can be morphed into a
rectangle with the help of the Infinity
principle now if you're really a tight
mathematician out there you know I've
done some fudging here just relax
then this is basically correct but you
know there's some loose moments in the
park but remember what would the venue
it is come on give me a break but that's
the gist of it okay so that's an example
of the power of infinity that they also
notice that the shape becomes best at
infinity you know the optometrist test
keep going
things get better at infinity that's a
key principle in in calculus things are
better at infinity okay next so as I
said earlier there are these three
obsessions curves motion and change and
for the sake of accessibility I'm
probably going to mostly talk about
curves it's the least technical but we
can talk about how calculus has
revolutionized our understanding of
things that move on the earth and in the
heavens and anything that changes
whether it's traffic on the highway
whether it's the level of HIV virus in
the bloodstream of patients who are
infected I mean it's been applied to
everything under the Sun next so back to
curves just because I want to show you
one more masterpiece of Archimedes to
show you another a little bit of how the
infinity this is actually more honestly
what Archimedes did take a circle you
can make shapes with a circle I mean
they started with circles that was the
fundamentally first mysterious shape and
then you could make the shapes like a
cone and if you slice a cone and with
planes of different tilts you can make a
shape like that called an ellipse or you
can make a shape like this if you slice
parallel to the side of the cone you
make a shape called a parabola so
originally these were thought of as
sections of a cone and they're still
called conic sections ellipses and
parabolas and also hyperbola so let's
not bother with them for now so next
so one question that Archimedes wondered
about this this is like 250 BC he's in
Syracuse on the island of Sicily a part
of the larger Greek Empire the Romans
would like to invade and the fact they
do invade and try to take over
Archimedes you know take some time away
from his math to build war machines that
according to legends you know Plutarch
tells us in his history that Archimedes
made these fearsome machines that could
grab the Roman ships out of the ocean
giant cranes lift them up shake them so
that the soldiers would you know awed
the sailors would come out like if you
were shaking sand out of your sandal you
know I don't know if it's really true
but but there's all kinds of stories
about Archimedes but we do know this
because he wrote these treatises that we
still have about how he found areas of
curved shapes so one was what's the area
of a shape like that so-called parabolic
segment next this is amazing here's his
strategy to figure out the area of this
curved shape he is going to regard it as
a sequence of shapes made of straight
lines so you know in cubist painting you
draw pictures of people or other things
Braque and Picasso they're using all
these rectilinear shapes Picatta
Archimedes is doing that in his vision I
think it's an amazing vision to see this
curved shape as this combination of
triangles so what he does is he puts a
big triangle inside and then there are
two smaller triangles like a shade of
gray sitting on the side of the original
big triangle and then you can see
there's a little bit of empty space left
under the parabola he could wedge in
more triangles in there and keep doing
that he's gonna exhaust all the area
until it's all nothing but triangles so
that's his concept but now which
triangles exactly should he put in there
next oh I should say before I get to
that here's the big punchline he's going
to show that the area of that parabolic
segment compared to the area of that
first big triangle there in the ratio
four to three
and that's not obvious but that's what
he's going to show the parabolic segment
is four thirds as big as the big
triangle
and if you are interested in music you
should think about the numbers four and
three
do you have any musical people here yell
is great at music you do music do you
but I'm wondering oh you did
wow there's a musical family are you
brother and sister yeah cheese but this
is a hard question I'm asking and do you
know anything about why four and three
are related to music you do why oh
[Music]
that's interesting could be a time
signature you have a fun oh good this is
now you're on the right track so an
octave is two to one tell us more what
you mean what do you mean two to one for
an octave like if I take two strings
suppose I was playing a guitar and I put
my finger on a fret halfway up the
string and I pluck one string and if it
was the same other the same string but
with the same tension and everything but
not with my finger on the fret the one
that's long and the one that's half as
long they will sound an octave apart
right the one that's short would be
octave higher twice the frequency if the
frequency if you do this with strings
but in the ratio four to three
Pythagoras and his people legend
according to legend discovered laws of
musical harmony the three to two ratio
makes do you know so 3 to 2 would be 1/5
4 to 3 would be called a fourth I think
so and I don't know music but my
daughter who's my younger daughter told
me think about the Star Wars theme
that's a third no that's a that's a
fifth that's those are separated by a
fifth sheep - alright but then she said
but here comes the bride
I didn't do it well bah bah bah bah bah
that's a fourth that's four to three
so a 4 to 3 ratio the point ok
the Florida 3 ratio is something every
self-respecting Greek knew 4 to 3 was
considered beautiful because it's
connect
to music and so you could imagine how
excited our communities would have been
that the parabolic segment to the big
triangle it's in a 4 to 3 ratio okay but
why why is it 4 to 3 so let's see the
argument he takes this triangle and now
the way he constructs that triangle is
he takes the line that defines the
bottom of the segment he slides it up
until it's just touching the parabola at
one point that's in the jargon the
tangent line try to be tangent to the
parabola at one point so if he then that
defines a unique point and then he
builds the triangle touching that point
then he's going to use that parallel
sliding trick to build new triangles
next slide so you see then he builds
those little triangles the same way
slides the sides parallel till they
touch at one point builds new triangles
and what he can prove with the geometry
that he knows and properties of the
parabola that he knows is that those new
triangles will have 1/8 the area of the
original big triangle not obvious but he
can prove that and that and he shows
that that rule is true at every stage
whenever he creates a new triangle by
this technique it will always have 1/8
the area of the triangle it came from
and so if you total up the areas so far
we had one for the big triangle 1/8 plus
1/8 makes 1/4 so we have 1 plus 1/4 and
then if you believe me about this rule
that you're always going to get a
quarter of what you had before you're
led to next an infinite series which is
1 plus 1/4 plus 1/16 plus dot dot and
that turns out to add up to 4/3 so if
you've had high school algebra you've
learned a formula for that but
Archimedes did not have high school
algebra because algebra is a product of
the Middle East right I mean algebra is
gonna be invented about like eight
hundred years later in places like
Baghdad and I mean there's a kind of
geometric algebra that the that the
Greeks know but still for them geometry
is the thing so he does his algebra this
way when he calculates this infinite
series he draws a picture which has four
squares here's a square of size one in
area the whole picture is four units of
area right because it's four big squares
so that's the 4 in 4/3 watch the
see what's going on you take one that's
one big square then you take a quarter
of that square that's the thing marked a
quarter then you take a quarter of that
that's the thing marked a sixteenth and
so the total of the grey is the infinite
series he wants but he says by
inspection I can see that that's
one-third of the whole shape right
because what is it it's a big square
plus a second size square plus a third
sky square but that's also copied over
here big square another one of size a
quarter the white ones you have three
copies of the same structure in this
picture of size four so four thirds is
occupied by the gray so that's what we
would call a proof without words but you
know what's really nice about Archimedes
here too now speaking to the rigorous
mathematicians for a second is he
actually calculates the error term
correctly he doesn't just say dot dot
dot I mean you're talk when you teach
calculus properly you don't say dot dot
you say calculate the error term and
make sure that the error term goes to
zero and the error term is that little
tiny square up in the corner and he
cannot see exactly how big it is you
know he could another words he can
calculate the finite series not just the
infinite series okay so anyway that's a
start that's an example of Archimedes
ingenuity with the tools he has which is
geometry and ingenuity but he doesn't
have algebra he doesn't even have
decimals right decimals are being
created over in India so this is a big
world story the story of calculus it's
not like don't think of it as just a
european greek thing it's not but but
this part of the story is okay next
so what about Archimedes today this is
another case of this invisible presence
of calculus you are using Archimedes all
the time when you go to the movies and
possibly when you go to the doctor but
you don't know it so what am I talking
about you know how he built up that
curved shape the parabolic segment out
of triangles well you can make a shape
in computer graphics out of triangles
that can approximate any smooth surface
so you can make a picture of a
mannequins head by just triangulating it
more and more finally and that is the
technology that goes into something like
the next slide this kind of movie
Jerry's game which you can find on
YouTube don't do it right now but but so
Jerry's game was the first animated
movie completely computer-generated
movie that had a human character that it
was emotionally expressive we had
earlier movies like Toy Story but that
was you know those are toys that this is
a real human being who acts like a
person except he's made of polygons in
fact he's made of triangles but millions
of them so you don't see the triangles
but they're there and and the people at
pixar who made this you know
animate all those polygons but how to
make a polygon that cut up sir how to
make a sequence of triangles that will
make the shape that you want an old
man's face with his wrinkles under his
eyes and so on there's a lot of calculus
in computing the right triangulation to
make whatever you want next so you know
this is probably a movie you know better
Shrek telling donkey that onions have
layers and his little trumpet like ears
is round belly these are all smooth
surfaces that required millions of
triangles and so this is the technology
that Pixar and DreamWorks and everybody
uses nowadays it's an Archimedean idea
that you can represent any smooth
surface with triangles next now here's a
little more medically oriented example
if you just think it's kind of frivolous
for kids movies it's not here's a
gentleman who you can see on the left
this is him before surgery
I've his eyes have been you know
pixelated because they for a privacy but
anyway this guy you can see his jaw is
sticking out in a way that it's not just
cosmetically on pleasing for him but but
I think was causing him medical problems
this malformation and then there's a
scan of his bones taken in a medical
scanner so that's him before the surgery
now what doctors would like to do is
figure out if they would cut out certain
bones in his jaw and then reattach
everything surgically you know sew him
back up what's his face gonna look like
after surgery and the issue is
there's a lot of other tissues than just
the bones bones are pretty rigid but
there's soft tissues the face is made of
skin there's all the tissues behind the
face there's cartilage there's you know
a lot going on tendons all kinds of
things to think about so the branch of
math that that's involved here is we
want to make a mathematical model of all
the soft tissues and bones in a person's
head such that when we change the
conditions by cutting out bones and
reconnecting things they're going to be
many elastic forces they're going to be
parts of the skin and cartilage and bone
that are pulling on each other with this
new configuration and things are going
to shift obviously that's the whole
point of doing the surgery so people
have made these elasticity models now
okay elasticity elasticity is a branch
of engineering and applied math that
uses calculus if you take a course in
elasticity in the engineering department
at Yale or anywhere else you will be
doing tensor calculus you'll be doing
partial differential equations it's
calculus okay it's been applied
everywhere and so I'm trying to say that
when this poor guy had his face
redesigned the doctors were able to tell
him what his new face would look like
the computer model said it would be that
third image from the left they did the
surgery and that's his new face and you
can see that the prediction basically
got it right now this has been
quantified by referred to the study in
the book you can check the original
paper if you want to see the data but I
mean with with calculus and computer
modeling and lots of careful scanning
and all this other stuff you can
essentially build like a flight
simulator for surgeons the surgeons can
do the study because you know it's very
serious to cut someone's bones you don't
want to do it wrong you're not gonna get
a second chance so they can practice on
virtual patients before they do the real
thing with the help of calculus and
computer model so that's an example but
now what does it have to do with
Archimedes well what when I talk about
this elasticity model what is the model
next slide it's the kind of thing that
is built on triangulation it's old
Archimedean idea except that instead of
just triangulating the face
I don't know if you can really see but
they've gone behind the face and they
have three-dimensional analogues of
triangles that are tetrahedra that are
modeling the soft tissues and they have
different stiffnesses and elastic
properties and so they have this
gigantic model of billions of polygons
and and simplices tetrahedra and other
things so that they can figure out all
the forces and how everything's gonna
rearrange itself after you do whatever
you're gonna do with the cutting of
bones so this is just to give you an a
sense of how today through computers and
calculus we are living Archimedes legacy
all over the place okay next all right
so I don't remember quite when we start
I'm just about ready to wrap up I'll
give you can I have like five more
minutes I just want to talk a little bit
about what you might think of as
calculus because everything I did so far
probably doesn't look like the calculus
you had I understand that and that's
because you know calculus was going on
for thousands of years before algebra
came along the the calculus you'll learn
nowadays is all algebra they're all
formulas it's a tremendously powerful
thing using symbols that came from the
east that came from India and the
Islamic world and gradually made its way
into Europe at the beginning of the
Middle Ages
so like 1200 1300 you start getting
algebra in Europe and algebra then
collides with geometry and that's when
differential calculus is soon born in
the middle of you know like say the
1600s or so but so 1800 years after
Archimedes algebra and geometry collide
but before Newton and Leibniz you have
people like firma and Descartes creating
the subject of analytic geometry this is
this fusion of taking a curve like here
I'm showing a parabola
just like Archimedes was studying but
whereas Archimedes thinks of it as a
section of a cone now to Descartes and
firma it's an equation like y equals x
squared the relation between these
symbols in this very familiar picture
that we think of as Cartesian
coordinates with x and y-axes all the
classical curves of the Greeks can now
be thought of as equation
and so you have this great you can play
two ways with them you can visualize
them or you can work on them as
equations so analytic geometry is a
great breakthrough that then sets the
stage for calculus in that now there's
all kinds of new curves you can make you
can write down an equation there's a new
curve it doesn't have to be a section of
a cone you could do anything you can
create a whole jungle of new curves and
start asking questions about them what's
the area under the curve or we saw how
Archimedes use a tangent line in his
constructions what's a tangent line
gonna be like you know now that we're
doing it with algebra so that became a
big question for our confer a Descartes
and for MA
and I just want to give you the
intuition about how to think about
tangent lines
imagine a microscope and I'm gonna zoom
in on this point so let's see the next
slide if i zoom in you don't see what
looks like a parabola anymore but I'm
now just sort of this is the part in my
microscope field of view the curve has
gotten straighter sort of like what we
saw when we were doing that Archimedean
pizza proof right in the bottom got
flatter and flatter this curve is going
to start getting straighter next slide
if we zoom in more it really looks very
straight I mean you can see from the
numbers Oh point five point five oh five
we have zoomed in a lot so under great
magnification a curve starts to look
like something made of straight pieces
and this is the great idea behind
differential calculus that you can
approximate curvy things with straight
things or what in the jargon we would
say local linearization but it just
means that you can think of a curve as
made of lots of straight pieces but they
have to be infinitesimally and this is
again the infinity principle that to
deal with the problem of a tangent line
to a curve defined by any equation we
can solve it by zooming in enough and
then figuring out slopes of straight
lines so I want to end with something
that is more modern still you know for
firma and Descartes
curves were just curves they still
wanted to do geometry but nowadays we
think of curves as meaningful about the
world curves
tell us about stock prices going up and
down
they show your blood pressure your heart
rate you know everything can be graphed
and so for us curves are now visual
representations of certain kinds of data
so let's see the next slide they can
represent in particular things that are
moving and changing the dynamic world
that calculus describes began with the
study of things that that could be
represented as curves so just to give
you a taste of what that's Mike let me
you look at the next slide I want to
just remind you of something so don't
start this video yet this is a video
taken in 2008 it was a at the Olympics
when Usain Bolt was running the hundred
meters so that long ago only 11 years
ago Usain Bolt is a sprinter from
Jamaica who doesn't look like a sprinter
he's 6 foot 5 very tall very gangly he's
also very mischievous Joker
he loves to joke around and he never
really ran the hundred meters that was
not his race he was known as a 200 meter
actually used to run the 400 meters a
longer race and he was great at that
because he wasn't so great at starting
but once he got going he was very fast
and but he sort of wanted to try the
hundred meters and his coaches said
you're never going to be any good you
know you don't look like a hundred meter
sprinter those guys are short and
muscular and he said I could you know I
could get muscular so they started
pumping him up he got more muscular he
had five races in the hundred meters
competitively at this time that he was
entering the Olympics so think of him as
a beginner ok don't we mutt done it five
times in competition but he was already
able to contend with the best in the
world and so I guess there is nothing to
do but just oh are we gonna have audio I
guess we'll find out let's see if this
will work because it's sort of fun to
hear the announcer let's try go ahead no
I guess not
well anyway you can see the runners are
getting themselves ready and watch what
happens
now do you see what he did at the end
where he put his arms down that is not
normal
he's coasting he's so far ahead he's
coasting that he's in fact he's slapping
his chest I mean you saw there was this
whole other group of runners the world's
best runners with clear daylight between
him and them and he's fooling around
going like that sorry banging his own
chest so and that's like I say he's not
being disrespectful he's just
mischievous he's celebrating a little
bit he's so far ahead so there was a
question let's see the next one I mean
that shows you at the end of the race
and you won't be able to see it from
where you are but if you look very very
closely I can tell you that that's his
shoelace he has an untied shoelace
so he's way way ahead and that question
among sports aficionados was if he had
run hard what time he set a new world
record of I think this was nine point
six nine how fast could he have run if
he had really run all the way to the end
so that's a calculus question that we
could answer so let's see the next slide
this is the way that they record
performances like this is that there are
detectors every 10 meters and so we know
where at what time he crossed 10 meters
20 meters 30 meters down the track so we
have this split times those are the dots
we don't have his position in between
the dots but with calculus we can fit a
curve in an optimal way two dots and you
know what's the smooth curve that has
zero velocity because we know it when he
began he wasn't running it he's in the
block you have to start with zero
velocity zero velocity would mean this
curve has to have a flat tangent it has
to that the slope tells you how fast
he's run when it gets steeper he's
moving faster so you can see at the
beginning he's not moving that fast but
then he gets faster and faster now what
we could do would this having fit the
curve through there we can then
calculate the slope at each point using
what I just said you zoom in as if with
a microscope
and then record the slopes at every
point and if you do that you get the
next slide which shows his velocity as a
function of time in meters per second so
you see he speeds up and then somewhere
after like about 8 seconds
he's very visibly slowing down which we
saw by just watching him as he's goofing
around at the end so you can answer
questions like what was his maximum
speed you can just read that off the
graph when did he achieve his maximum
speed and so on but I haven't actually
done the calculation of how fast could
he have gone if he kept running hard
because actually we don't need to do it
the next a few months later there was
the World Championships in Berlin and
then he didn't fool around so I don't
have the video of that although it's on
YouTube you could watch it if you want
but people who thought that something
might happen in Berlin so they went with
radar guns like the type that police
would use to you know first catching a
speeding car so they they put little
reflectors on the back of every runner
their aiming their lasers at the runners
and these things could measure data you
know like 100 times a second or
something like that and so the next
slide shows his speed as a function of
time as detected by the radar gun at
Berlin and you'll notice some
interesting thing his instantaneous
speed is that wiggly curve and the
average that's sort of going through the
Wiggles is shown dotted do you have any
idea why there were all those Wiggles oh
I'll take another young you're a Brit
here so faster should be on Jeopardy you
want to tell what do you think the
Wiggles are do what time for his feet to
leave the ground he'll though yep you're
seeing his individual strides you're
actually seeing the fact that when when
his I mean what is running running is a
series of leapings and landings right
and when he lands he's slowing down a
little bit and when he's leaping he's
going a little faster so that is all
being resolved in that Wiggly curve and
you'll I think there should be 41
because it's known that he takes 41
steps every time he runs the Hun
everybody else does 44 but he's tall so
he always does 41 steps 41 strides and
what I find interesting about this
picture is that we don't care about the
Wiggles having measured them we're not
interested in I mean they're sort of
interesting but if we really I mean what
we really want is the trend and I think
that there's a kind of metaphor here
that if you start getting too precise
sometimes you're picking up information
you're not that interested in and so
this has been a recurrent theme in the
story of calculus that like I said it
has creative fantasies in it where it
ignores certain things and focuses on
others and it seems to me that this is a
case where you know we could have just
drawn a smooth curve through his data
and we would have gotten really just as
much information as this more
microscopic view so yes it's true if we
start going very microscopic calculus
may break down but maybe we don't care
maybe we've really gotten the essence by
looking at this bigger picture so this
was said better than I'm saying it now
by Picasso can I have the next slide
yeah art is a lie that makes us realize
truth right I mean no picture is really
realistic and yet if it's if it's great
art it often captures the essence of the
truth so I would like to suggest that
the calculus has done the same thing for
us in science it's a kind of a lie that
has helped us realize the truth thank
you
thank you so much for fantastic talk so
I hope I'm open Americans okay happy to
take any talks or criticisms compliments
you name it okay yes declaration yeah
sure that's that as a teaser isn't it
okay here's what the story I tell in
that in the book infinite powers but
it's not my idea this is an idea that
goes to back to the historian of science
I Bernard Colin a great Newton scholar
so so Colin points out that the founding
fathers in the u.s. all you know these
Enlightenment thinkers we're very much
interested in in Newton and Euclid and
logical reasoning so in particular think
about the structure of the the preamble
in the Declaration right there's this
famous ringing line we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal etcetera this this it's
interesting phrase we hold these truths
to be self-evident where does that come
from if you look at Euclid so Euclid who
gave us the first geometry textbook
begins with the self-evident truths in
math we call them the axioms right the
axioms are the things that are supposed
to be self-evident you just accept them
of course they're true and then starting
with the self-evident truths and
commonly agreed-upon rules of reasoning
you erect this edifice of propositions
and theorems building on the axioms now
if you look at the rhetorical structure
of the Declaration it has a Euclidean
structure because now what that is it
starts we hold these truths to be
self-evident then the axioms are listed
the right to you know pursuit of
happiness and all that and then there's
an argument and then there's an
inescapable conclusion a theorem which
is essentially that the colonies have
the right to separate themselves from
from the tyrant king so why would
Jefferson have written this Euclidean
doc can I call it Euclidean why because
I mean because
rhetorically it goes back to Euclid but
if you look at Newton in the Principia
so-so Euclid is writing about geometry
but Newton is using this geometrical
style of argumentation to write about
the world because the system of the
world where he begins with the
proposition he begins with axioms which
are his laws of motion and then using
logic derives how comets move how the
planets move the tides I mean in other
words if you want to make an argument
that no one can argue with to the
thinkers of the Enlightenment the best
way you could do it was to use a
geometrical style self-evident truths
first theorems later and I'm not making
this up I mean you can see it in Spinoza
so in Spinoza's ethics he the actual
title of Spinoza's ethics book is ethics
demonstrated in geometrical order he
tries to derive the rules of ethics with
geometrical reasoning that's considered
irrefutable so I really think it's no
accident and like I say but I Bernhard
Cohen had the idea first that the
declaration is this quintessential
Enlightenment document and just to top
it off we know that Jefferson had a
Newton Euclid fetish so for instance he
had a death mask of Newton that's the
kind of thing people used to do right
someone is dead you make a big wax or I
don't know what you do you make some
kind of impression of their face and
then it's like whoa cool I have Newton's
face so so Jefferson had one of those
and he also wrote to John Adams back
when they were no longer presidents and
were just kind of shooting the breeze in
1812 I think it was he's writing to jet
to John Adams and he says you know like
I'm really happy to be done with
politics and he says I've given up
newspaper good up reading newspapers for
Herodotus and Thucydides Newton and
Euclid and I find myself much too
happier so so that's the argument but
but those we also see Jefferson using
Newtonian principles like he designs a
plow that will cut the soil in the
optimal way he uses a branch of math
called calculus of variations what's the
correct shape of a plow
minimum resistance as it's going through
the dirt and to put that you know
remember he's interested in agriculture
to put to plow as much dirt as fast as
you can as easily as you can
he doesn't know calculus of variations
Jefferson but he knows that that's what
he needs to know and he gets the help of
a professor at Penn to help him design
this optimal plow which you can still
see down and monta so what was that I
pronounce it cello
yeah what have you been there Monticello
have you been yeah Jefferson's all place
yet yeah it's there anyway yes good so
you have a question too or comment yes
hi so you talked a little bit about how
calculus / geometry and algebra were
developed separately and I've noticed
that I guess quantum mechanics comes to
mind that you can look at it and either
kind of a differential calculus way or a
linear algebra way with the calculus
being more intuitive but computationally
more difficult and the algebra being
less intuitive but computationally
easier and I was wondering if you could
kind of speak to the relationship
between the two sides I think I missed
one word early in what you said are you
asking for the relationship between
algebra and geometry and the two ways of
thinking was that yeah yeah okay I mean
I feel like I missed a key word but that
okay that's just the question okay well
yeah I mean they sort of represent two
styles of thinking right that that
algebra has this virtue of being very
systematic you can as I said earlier
could massage equations manipulate
symbols you in a way don't have to think
like you don't have to have insight to
do algebra you just have to do the
bookkeeping correctly and that's one of
the great strengths actually live notes
when he's doing calculus his version of
calculus says and actually he's the one
who gives us the word calculus he says
you know what the virtue of my calculus
at first he calls it my calculus my way
of thinking my style of reasoning Newton
doesn't refer to it as calculus by
though he calls it fluxions
he's interested in the world in flux so
but anyway so Leibniz says something
like the virtue of my calculus is that
it frees the mind frees the imagination
you don't have to spend any effort
thinking you're just it's like knitting
you know you just move the symbols
around it's all good whereas geometry
although it's extremely intuitive and
visual requires tremendous ingenuity and
you know this is partly why it takes two
thousand years after Archimedes for
anyone to really advanced calculus much
beyond what he did because he was such a
towering genius that and there were no
tools for everyone else you know I mean
if you couldn't reason like Archimedes
geometrically or invent I mean
exaggerating because there were things
that were done after him but it was very
progress was very slow when it was just
geometry so algebra really did speed
things up but I mean to me algebra is
quite sterile I find al Jabar is not
about anything
whereas geometry is about something it's
just very hard and so when you put
geometry and algebra together now you're
really cooking and that's what happened
in the 1600s at one thing I feel a
little bad about and I want to I can't
really properly correct it but I just
want to show you that I'm woke and I
mean I really am I'm aware of this is
that women are part of the story and so
are people in India and China and Japan
and in the Mayan civilization I mean
there's a lot of calculus being done
around the world I mean with women
honestly it's only sort of around the
1800s that women start to be allowed to
don't even go to university and hear
lectures and stuff but but as soon as
they're able you get great people Sophie
Germain and Sophia kovalevskaya and
certainly in the 20th century we've got
lots of tremendous women mathematicians
all over the world so so although I've
told it a certain kind of dead white
male European way I don't mean it that
way and it's not that is not an accurate
picture of what really happened so I do
try to tell it the right way in the book
including Katherine Johnson you know who
we all know now from hidden figures you
know who helped put astronauts on the
moon and bring them back safely using
calculus of course yes just very quickly
thank you so much and also if the
internet had been around
when Luke was looking he would have
found out that in 1910 Sylvanas Thompson
wrote calculus made easy he didn't know
he looked at that book he absolutely
looked at that book yeah yeah that's one
of the books he looked at it's a famous
book calculus made easy that's the title
no he looked and found it I'm sorry if I
had meant it it sounded like I said you
looked for it but didn't find it no he
did find it
he read calculus made easy by Thompson
and many people say that that is still
the best book to learn calculus from so
you may if you're interested you may
want to look at that book it is quite
funny and quite skillful pedagogically
but it's sort of an old book it's a
hundred years old and I think it's you
know it probably has some deficiencies
but for whatever reason it didn't really
work for Herman Wouk no yes oh wait okay
who's next I have two related fast
questions at first thank you for the
talk I hope even like high school
students or first-year college students
get exposed to calculus this way and my
first my first take is the first idea
you were talking about that nature
speaks calculus yeah what how would you
think if we reframe this saying that
calculus is our only tool to measure
only what we can measure and only what's
quantifiable because that sounded to me
that it eliminates so many things in
life that are not quantifiable and
they're very abstract and they exist in
nature and relatedly which is very fast
and related my second question is you
seem to embrace modernism to a great
extent on the talk which is
understandable because we're talking
about calculus but if you can have a
brief answer to that like what's your
take on post modernist thought that
question the rigidity and the privilege
stone of modernism okay so the first
question is is interesting let's see if
I can rephrase it so you're saying that
calculus does well at measuring at
quantifying the things we can measure to
some extent but the things we can't
measure
or whatever doesn't have anything to say
about those and I think I probably agree
with you I do I I'm not sure maybe I
mean because the state of not being able
to measure something is often a
temporary state right sometimes
something can't be measured now but can
be measured later and my claim would be
that when it can be measured but maybe
your claim too would be that once we can
measure it calculus will turn out to be
just the right thing for it would you
agree with that
not really
uh-huh
so no so there are things that we can't
measure do they affect us in any way
these other things okay right so things
like that uh-huh
yeah right so calculus of course would
have it be hard-pressed to say anything
about that so I think I accept that
first point I mean just that there's
something I wonder if though if I'm
agreeing too quickly because well just
that there's some in towards the end of
the book I mentioned one thing that I
regard as very spooky to me that makes
me think but I don't think it will
refute or even contradict what you're
saying because it's still in the realm
of what can be measured I'm just
thinking of a case where there are
certain properties of subatomic
particles of electrons that have been
measured and accurately predicted to
eight decimal places with this fineman's
part of physics quantum electrodynamics
that that we can understand something in
the gyromagnetic ratio of the electron
can be calculated eight digits after the
decimal point why am I making a big deal
about that I mean that's that is so
unbelievably accurate but it wasn't
built into the theory we didn't know it
would agree it does agree to eight
digits now you're not saying it's some
kind of like equivalent to faith or
social construction or are you I mean
I'm saying it can't possibly be because
it works so well and we didn't know that
it would work that well ahead of time
that to me it's capturing something that
I want to call the truth or close to the
truth I wouldn't say it's the end-all
be-all truth because truth is always
provisional but it's a very close to the
truth and if you want to tell me you
don't believe there is such a thing as
truth that anything can we really do
disagree but but I don't hear you saying
that I think you're saying there's some
domains where we have sort of almost
hear you saying the boring domains the
things we can measure or no you're not
saying that you don't want to go that
far
okay okay you're just raising the issue
yeah well certainly the things that
can't be quantified I don't see what
calculus would have to say about them
because as I say it's all about this
principle of regarding problems it
applies to problems that can be viewed
as continuous in some way blah blah blah
so so for religion or whatever it does I
don't think it will have anything to say
about that but then you asked about
modernism and I don't feel well enough
equipped to even know what that I don't
know enough about post-modernism to know
how to respond to that okay maybe I
should try someone else's comment or a
question yes
let's hold on there someone is gonna try
to pass a microphone over to you that's
okay that everyone will be happy if you
just talk in there um you mentioned the
title of the book that calculus is the
language of God right this is what
Feynman said I think I personally don't
believe in God in case you're curious
okay
but both anyway well then okay good you
could ask I could pretend and if god
thank you if God if the reason for our
feelings is a result of God you know
everything is permeated through God then
calculates it should be able to mention
or anything
let's see or
or Fineman to know when he was talking
about and calculus really isn't the
language kind what is it what is this a
comment or a question you're saying it's
more of which is like a rhetorical
question that if I if calculus is God's
language and God should be all powerful
and most conceptions of God and anything
again well a couple of big if statements
there yeah I don't know I I don't know I
don't okay so the word God gets used a
lot in different ways right Einstein
talks about God but he was careful to
say not the God who cares about you know
whether you've been naughty or nice it's
it's the God the creator of the universe
God who makes the laws of nature etc or
maybe just the laws of himself like he
always used to say it's talking about
Spinoza's God meaning the God that is
nature not to God not a personal God who
cares about sin and things like that so
that if we just mean nature
I mean debate it's still a big mystery I
do feel this is a mystery that's running
throughout the story as I tell it that
why why can math I do actually didn't
really raised this question clearly let
me try to raise it now why why does math
work in yeah okay let's suppose we
restrict ourselves to the domain you're
talking about the domain of things that
can be measured it's still a question
why does nature obey logic in particular
human logic
that's it's not obvious to me that that
should be possible we're not the best
thing imaginable where you know a few
generations removed from primates and
and we have logic that can get the
gyromagnetic ratio of the electron to
eight digits that's weird
that our puny logic matches what really
goes on in the universe this well it
didn't I don't know why that worked why
does it work this is the question that
Eugene figner famously asked you know
the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and lots of people have
wondered about this some would say it's
because God made the world very orderly
others say if the world were very
disorderly we would not be able to
evolve to even our puny level of
intelligence like only universes that
support enough order to allow
intelligent life was the only universes
we can observe so it sort of that's the
anthropic view of why the universe makes
sense yes oh okay oh yes please go ahead
um so I was like umm so I've been
wondering like I've researched about the
black hole picture like like I wanted to
one like I was wondering did calculus
contribute to that like in a big level
or because I know that calculus
contributes to stuff like does it
contribute like greatly to the black
hole picture or to the black hole
picture do you mind talking about that
we have a put like one of the world's
experts right here she actually helped
make the black hole picture I think it's
fair to say well you tell us yes
absolutely calculus is really
fundamental because as you saw there
were curves that needed to be computed
to be put together that's a great
question and probably a great place to
stop why don't we go to the reception
thank you oh the reception yes please
join us at the reception
[Music]